16 million Americans served in the
military during World War two and it's
estimated that fewer than half a million
of those veterans are still alive more
than 50 of them though attended this
morning's ceremony in Normandy marking
the 75th anniversary of d-day Anthony
Mason is there and he's leading our car
bread cheese with our senior foreign
correspondent Mark Phillips Anthony Tony
the history books about d-day have been
written and rewritten over the decades
of course but for the veterans who came
ashore on these beaches the events of
June 6th are not history but their life
stories mark you've been with some of
these vets over the past couple of days
retracing their footsteps on this very
special anniversary yes well with each
major anniversary the veterans get fewer
and fewer and the trip for them coming
here of course gets harder and harder
and it is fascinating to hear why people
now in their 90's make the effort and
those are the ones that hit us in the
afternoon a lot of veterans come back to
Normandy to come to terms with their
past for 97 year-old Vern aller this
visit is about his life now about
sharing his memories with his wife of
ten years Ruth we never had one one tank
not one tank d-day in our sector Vern
Haller had landed at Omaha Beach the
site of the worst American carnage of
the Normandy landings he came in at
h-hour plus one just an hour after the
invasion began when the beach was the
killing zone because we were targets
exposed on the beach Vern aller was a 22
year old Texan with a mortar unit
supporting the first waves of infantry
but he's never been the kind of guy to
tell war stories to the side I never
forgot it you can't dwell on it
I mean
the guy said well I suppose a basket
cases but Verne thought it was now or
never to share his experiences with Ruth
and so he took her on this tour through
the once bloody Normandy battlefield
country we were rookies as far as combat
was concerned another Jeep there's a lot
of Second World War nostalgia at times
like this but Verne doesn't need any
visual clues why you don't forget it
you can't I can tell you this stuff that
happened ten minutes after we landed you
know and now he's told that stuff to
Ruth why is it important that it be
passed on because the kids today do not
know the sacrifice
that were given
for for their freedom Wow
coming back did more than revived
memories for Bernal Earth it reminded
him why he had come here the first time
I think I should cheat sit at school not
just d-day the Iwo Jima and some of
those islands and Hitler and Tojo had to
be eliminated
still clarity on the job Vern Oliver
came to do 75 years ago it's still
amazing to me mark you know seeing these
veterans share these stories with their
families really only now
well he's been married to Ruth for ten
years they married obviously quite late
in his life and and he hadn't really
told her any of this stuff and the
opportunity came up for him to to take
this tour and I said we can bring your
wives carers whatever along he asked her
if she wanted to go and she said yes and
they are a lot of that going on here
today Mark Phillips thanks let's send it
back to you all in New York all right
Anthony thank you yeah the past shapes
your future